dont ce jt par téléphone rémy mamia ce
médecin à sainte suzanne sur l'île de la
réunion
bonjour rémy mamayas merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france la réunion a
de nouveau mis sous cloche donc dès ce
week end
bonne ou mauvaise solution ben bonne
solution c'est comme bonjour à tous et
comme pour la guadeloupe ou la
martinique on est dans une situation où
nous a heureusement on a deux variants
majeur c'est le delta et le sud africain
avec une augmentation des cas
extrêmement brutal beaucoup plus
présente encore que dans les
statistiques puisque on a au départ on
avait un ou deux cas tous les mois je
tends chaque cabine et maintenant j'en
ai jusqu'à 500 jours donc c'est vraiment
pas drôle
on a la même réticence à la vaccination
mais il rappelle que la liberté de
chacun s'arrête là où commence celle des
autres et que quand on est quelqu'un de
qui créa sa liberté on est tous d'accord
qu à liberté merveilleuse et je rejoins
tout le monde là dessus cependant la
liberté des devoirs et que quand on ne
se satinent pas et qu'on vit en
communauté
eh bien on expose des autres et la
maladie ceux qui sont vaccinées à
l'heure actuelle ne se retrouve pas en
réanimation
ceux qui sont pas vacciné
malheureusement surtout des jeunes
maintenant se retrouvant nos suggestions
et certains vaisselle donc si j'ai des
chiffres de que j'ai reçu aujourd'hui le
taux d'incidence et 423 vous sembliez
d'habitants le taux de positivité et à
8,2 plutôt de dépistage et augmenter
mais le r de référence et à 1,44 on a
sur neuf cent mille habitants 240 3566
personnes ces 28 % taxe d'accise et avec
des doses et on est à 3 127 bis avec son
crew qu'une seule de ses frères 38% on
est très loin derrière la france et la
france est très loin derrière le canada
où d'autres pays au niveau de la
vaccination globale donc la liberté de
chacun s'arrête là où commence celle des
autres et quand malheureusement les gens
ne l'entendent pas sous de faux
prétextes
on se retrouve être confiné donc
responsabilité à chacun
jean castex le pré
ministre a évoqué hier une situation
dramatique dans de nombreux territoires
d'outre-mer dont le vote donc il a
évoqué des territoires d'outre-mer je
cite à rétif à la vaccination
votre réaction est ce que la réunion est
rétive à la vaccination
depuis le discours de macron beaucoup
plus de gens nous demandent à être
vaccinés ils nous demandent des conseils
par rapport au vaccin puisque c'est vrai
que le brouhaha médiatique qui jouait
sur youtube ou ailleurs avec des
histoires à dormir debout sont les
passions sont un peu déroutés et que
certains interview sata médecins sont
contre et des interviews qui sont toutes
contradictoires les unes des autres
la problématique c'est qu'on doit sortir
de cette crise qui est la première
pandémie mondiale et la planète est
arrêté et que des patients commencent à
prendre conscience qu'il faut s'obstiner
maintenant les rendez vous sur entre -
c'est la faute commise son père d'akio
des permanents les rendez-vous sont
extrêmement obtenir on parle d'une
faible couverture vaccinale dans votre
département près de 27 ans que je
n'étais réunionnais qui serait donc
vacciner qui aurait complété dans
l'ordre de leur schéma vaccinal 45 pour
la voiture portant sur le règlement 45%
ensemble pour l'ensemble des français
donc à ces mêmes en plus loin on est
loin et on martin - martinique également
on est même encore beaucoup plus loin et
ce qu'est une défiance face au vaccin
dans les dom-tom généralement oui une
défiance évident c'est à dire que même
en france et une défiance les jours 10
et on n'a pas assez réfléchi on n'a pas
été assez loin on n'a pas c'est vrai que
tout ça est vrai et on n'a pas une
vision à longue distance maintenant à
court terme
les gens qui sont vaccinées ne vont pas
en réanimation il faut juste une petite
pathologie c'est le seul danger qui
avait si vous prenez la rn des vaccins
et rennes qui sont freezer et modern art
et a pratiquement à danger aucun du
moins à l'heure actuelle après on sait
pas dans le temps ce que ça donnera par
contre on sait que la phase aller garder
des troupes de l'accusation on sait que
les tiennent à une bonne circulation et
en plus c'est d'indiquer la barre est
donc on est aux situations où les gens
ont voulu tout ça donc évidemment
l'information n'est plus comme à
l'époque il ya des siècles où personne
n'était au courant de rien là tout le
monde est au courant de tout donc je
peux comprendre qu'un mais ça des
messages
divergent constamment font que les gens
sont troublés et puis à la réunion il
faut rétif en disant mais qu'est ce
qu'ils nous font ils vont nous
empoisonner enfin rihanna qui me font
des discours on dirait qu'ils ont des
déplacements sur la plaie t il encore
des zones partiel mais c'est quand même
assez effrayant et pour les convaincre
c'est un énorme travail qui nous épuise
tous puisque non seulement mes confrères
animations sont épuisés parce qu'elle
rénovation est plein mais on est on est
tous épuisés parce qu'on a une flopée de
patients qui viennent et qu'ils soient
moins c'est donc voir les calmer et de
leur faire comprendre que la vaccination
deviennent nécessaires
c'est la liberté de chacun s'arrête là
où commence celle des autres vous mettez
en danger la vie d'autrui vous mettez en
danger la vie des autres et sert
confinement donc chez vous à la réunion
et puis en martinique on parle également
de couvre feu du côté de la guadeloupe
saint-martin saint-barthélemy est ce que
ça va pénaliser le secteur touristique
est primordial pour les territoires
ultramarins
ça vous comprenez quand même si on le
comprend parfaitement
je vais la logique quel que soit le prix
le gouvernement l'a fait c'est admiratif
c'est très bien de problèmes ces cadres
ont le prix commence à coûter très cher
la problématique c'est que le tourisme
c'est aussi toutes les zones de tourisme
où les gens ne porte pas de masque scala
veigneau personne ne contrôle des
chantiers portent le masque et personnes
qui en disent à monde sait
c'est aussi les gens qui démarre par
avion et qui est de la population
dénoncent comme étant ceux qui emmène la
maladie le détail est arrivé tout cela
donc la question c'est évidemment que
c'est un c'est un dilemme énorme et que
le tourisme est une des premières
productions des plaidé déside française
mais la problématique c'est peut-on
continuer à cette vitesse là ça devient
délirant
justement le préfet de guadeloupe part
d'un pic épidémique à venir d'une
violence et d'une brutalité qu'on
n'avait jamais vu jusqu'où en bois de
loupe vous ou travaillent dans le
domaine de la santé vous ressentez ça
également à la réunion on sait qu'à une
intervention de l'armée pourra peut-être
un hôpital de campagne en martinique ça
pourrait vous aider vous à la réunion
bien sûr bien sûr les powervr où il ya
des commandes et porte-hélicoptères qui
nous a et b entre mayotte et la réunion
la problématique c'est que là ça va très
vite qu'on voit l'augmentation
constamment qui valent à grande vitesse
et puis sincèrement les proviseurs le
premier kovy celui qui était le phrase
que 2 de chine
c'était un patient qu'aucune des deux à
trois patients après on est monté à 6
est avec l'anglais
là avec le détail certains disent qu'on
arrive à 1000 justement un bal en parle
on parle des variants vous avez parlé le
virus la souche à l'initial le vario
anglais dans une antique d'africains
brésilien le variant indien c'est le
delta maintenant on parle également du
variant avec sinon on a l'impression
qu'on n'en voit pas le bout djillali
annane l'un de vos confrères un chef du
service de réanimation de l'hôpital
raymond-poincaré de garches en région
parisienne a dit en mars dernier qu'il
faudra attendre une décennie pour un
retour à la leur à la normale malgré la
vaccination dont vous parlez malgré les
restrictions
sanitaires mal quel port du masque
obligatoire malgré les gestes barrières
on a l'impression de ne pas voir le bout
du tunnel à quand la fin de tout ça vous
comprenez les français en ont marre
quand même mais je comprends que les
fonds sont les ras-le-bol et j'en fais
partie je vous rappelle un choix
français qui en a ras le bol parce que
je bosse comme un fou constamment donc
un moment on en a marre et on est mal
payé et poney se comprend c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose je
connais notamment vous confrères et il a
raison la troisième chose c'est qu'on a
eu plus d'un demi million devrions donc
une grande partie a disparu mais seuls
les plus virulents reste est à chaque
fois et des mines le précédent qui était
encore qu était déjà virulent donc on
est dans une course à l'échalote ou de
plus en plus ça change maintenant la
viktwa avantages des vaccins et rennes
c'est qu'en un an et demi deux mois on
peut faire un nouveau vaccin qui
marchera sur le variant suivant notre
problématique ce sens et il est sur la
planète est à l'arrêt économiquement
c'est horrible c'est comme pour le
touriste et le reste c'est quand même
problématique donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
merci à la problématique
merci rémi mami est d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste à sainte suzanne sur
les de la réunion qui va donc être à
nouveau confiné pour deux semaines à
partir de ce week end